In order to mine this site for the data we
need, we need to look at how we programmatically construct requests
in order to pull each page of data that we're
going to need. Remember each time through, we're going to be
passing a carrier value and an airport value. So the
best way, I think, to do this is to use the
browser to tell us how it makes requests to the site.
Because the browser is obviously
successfully making those requests and receiving
the results. Now to do that, We can take a
look at the network tab. Now I've just opened this so
at this point there are no network requests captured. In
order to get those what we're going to need to do
is submit our request again. Now its possible when you
do that if you've had the page open for a while
that you'll actually get an error page instead if that's the
case just copy this into a new tab and look it
as if you're loading it for the first time.
Simply trying to reload the page won't work for
you. Alright, so let's scroll to the top here.
And we can see right here that a post request
was submitted. If we click on that, that will
allow us to actually take a look at the HTTP
that was sent across, the request itself, as it's
encoded as HTTP, in order to retrieve this page full
of data. This is the same page we've been
looking at all along. Now, what I'm interested in is
exactly what data is submitted for this particular form.
So going back to the Network tab, what I want to
do is scroll down until I find Form Data,
and right away I realize that we have more work
to do. Than we might have originally expected. This is
a perfect example of why we want to use the
browser to figure out how to construct our requests. To
this point, we've been operating under the admittedly naive assumption that
all we were going to need to submit were the carrier
and airport as the form data in order to fetch each
page we're interested in. But we can see right here
that there are at least three more fields that we're going
to need to submit, and it's not clear at all to
us at this point where this value comes from. So that's
more work to do for us. But this is exactly
the type of situation that this particular class is about. In
some sense, we're essentially bending the web to our will. This
is where we're really getting into the meat of data wrangling.